this is so important to me this is
what's so telling the leftists they
always say well hold on a second
palestine is not hamas you can't hold
the people of palestine accountable for
their democratically elected terrorist
leadership
but rasheeda rasheeda sweetheart you are
the one drawing the link that hamas and
palestinian human rights that they're
one and the same
question of the day i'm not a
conspiratorial person generally
uh i don't think rashida taleb is a
terrorist i think she's sympathetic to
terrorists
and i'm going to build my case here i
want to hear what you think after this
whole israel situation going on this
last weekend
along with everything else i'm about to
present to you not necessarily a
terrorist
but i think that like if she wanted to
change her line of work
she could be she could have hamas dental
in a company car
context here last week of course rashida
labe was denied entry into israel
there's more to it but let's see a clip
for those who missed this is a country
that has just made a huge error i
believe and
they're gonna probably have to pay the
cost of it my goal is to see my
grandmother
um you know again she's in her 90s this
could be my last chance to see her
well apparently that wasn't her goal so
this is important people to know first
off her and ill and omar listed
palestine in the itinerary didn't even
mention israel
and something that people need to
understand i saw a headline i think was
from washington post that said
uh rashida taleb is allowed to enter
israel under one condition no no no
israel did not provide rashidali with
any conditions this is important to note
she was the one who sent a letter
to i believe the foreign minister that
said hey i really want to see my
grandmother
and by the way i promise not to do any
of the media not to to encourage any
boycotts or protests
all israel did they didn't name any
conditions all they said was
all right those sucks
that's it they said all right and then
she said you know what
i will not go under your condition you
sent the letter
this is a crazy person by the way the
reason we're doing this video is because
she blocked us at the time of
writing this segment and doing it she
blocked us on twitter which the courts
have ruled
is illegal updates to follow with the
half asian kraken
um so since we can't respond there we'll
respond here here are some examples of
of teles uh ties to terrorism so yeah
number five let's just start with her
district
okay she's representative of michigan's
13th congressional district
a lot of people don't necessarily know
this but it's an ongoing joke for people
who live in michigan
comment people from michigan dear born
to stan it's a support center
for middle eastern terror probably
sleeper cells there okay there was a
local business actually a restaurant i
used to go to
lashich which turned into palm palace
and when you what's funny is when you
research this story
it says oh the guy who was deported like
he wants to come back to the united
states because
he was uh he was deported because of tax
evasion and no no he was a
he was he wasn't just taxable he was
funneling money to hezbollah
it seems like that's a key detail that's
a little bit bigger than just tax
include
yeah yeah and they've been by the way
many michigan residents arrested for
joining isis
conspiring uh and terrorist plots um
these are this is from an area that
delayed represent this is important this
happens
i know you'll say well does someone are
they responsible for everyone in their
district no no but this happens
disproportionately in dearborn michigan
nowhere else maybe it'll start happening
in minnesota i don't know because i hear
that
but this is like the first sort of
islamic immigrant haven where it was
very largely
you know demographically islamic and
it's been going on there for a very
long time in record numbers do we
seriously think that these people aren't
the ones who elected her for that reason
she said she sees herself as their
representative in her own words she says
she's more of a palestinian in congress
than anywhere else honestly i've never
felt more palestinian
than i ever felt in congress even in
palestine when i'm visiting my
grandmother
i'm more american american like to the
palestinian
but i'm more palestinian in the halls of
congress than i am anywhere in the
country in the world
i don't know what that means yeah you
know they're just trying to say with
them yeah there's a there's a lot of
places in the country that are that have
a large muslim population that are
fantastic and wonderful and we're just
saying
basically that's fine you can have a
different opinion just not death to
america death to israel
i think the line kind of it's definitely
there it probably is a little earlier
definitely there or even the let me into
israel i promised not to be a dick
all right i wanted to be a dick
an oppression oppression depression now
take that and add rockets and you've got
hamas
uh here's another example we've talked
about this television avid supporter of
care
council on american islamic relations uh
she even spoke i think we have a clip at
their annual banquet the muslims are
coming
well guess what that's a terrifying
phrase holy [ __ ]
only everywhere in all kinds of
different governments but
wow we're in the united states congress
i bet you a nightmare the muslims are
coming stop their children
exactly the dearborn residents are
coming
okay for people watching on youtube that
doesn't make any sense that was behind
the paywall you should join my club yeah
you really should just to be clear the
u.s department of justice listed care as
an unindicted co-conspirator funneling
money to hamas
the uae is recognized care as a
terrorist organization alongside al
qaeda and isis so we're not making this
up
care members but they provided more than
half of the donations for uh
various political campaigns yeah well
we're all a second this is where the
justice democrats about bribing
politicians was over fifty thousand
dollars i think from cairo
oh wow wow they talk about oh well
you're bribing politicians of course
it's the bribe when it's a terrorist
organization you're a little fuzzy on
the rules there tank
how can walmart give this much to mitch
mcconnell well hold on a second what
about
uh the terrorist organization
i mean we can't we don't want to be
sticklers
reasonable discussion all right another
example now we're talking about this the
kids just keep on coming i'm building a
case here
um muslims of america uh jamaat ul fukra
i believe
so rashida donated and supported the
campaign of a congressional candidate
i want to make sure i get this name
right tahira i'm a tool what dude
probably wrong but you know this is
america that's enough get them to
get them to pronounce bobby i'm sure
it's the same kind of problem on al
jazeera
and then then they give 20 million to
young turks
uh so he was a board member of care and
a lawyer for muslims for america muslims
of america sorry this is important
it was led by sheikh gillani and it
functions the branch of the pakistani
terrorist organization
jamaat ulfukra okay according to fbi
documents jelani's followers in north
america are quote encouraged to travel
to pakistan to receive religious and
military terrorist training from sheikh
jilani
and his organization has been tied to
many terrorist training cells in the
united states
rashida taleb giving money to this
organization this organization's
head lawyer with great vigor and zeal
might have
by the way hit notification bell if you
haven't or just bookmark this page we
upload a new video every single day
of course full show you miss a ton of
content at mug club live with cutter.com
because this video of course is not
monetized
another example will be this one is
obvious but that's what i wanted to go
to kind of some some examples that are
off the beaten path
hamas right her ties with hamas and i
know people were just saying are you
talking about her with a mosque because
she's a muslim from dearborn no
so that would be enough but um jake
tapper recently i don't know if it was
recently he compared remember at one
point hamas i think to white
supremacists
which is an apt comparison if you look
at islamists and
what they believe certainly as it
relates to jews an al jazeera journalist
responded to jake tapper saying that
this was bigotry in islamaphobia
okay so i know this is a bit of a runner
on clay
piled on and said that comparing
palestinian human rights to human woman
human i've been doing hopper's voice too
long for that
pedestrian boy human um
she said comparing palestinian human
rights advocates to terrorist white
nationalists is fundamentally
a lie this is so important this is
what's so telling the leftists they
always say well hold on a second
palestine is not hamas you can't hold
the people of palestine
accountable for their democratically
elected terrorist leadership
they're separate they're not one and the
same but rasheeda rasheeda sweetheart
you are the one drawing the link that
hamas and palestinian human rights
that are one and the same you are saying
palestine when the other person was
talking about hamas
you defended hamas by saying palestine
so the liberal lexicon palestine equals
hamas
that's important yeah i think people
need to notice that because
they're not we didn't say that didn't
you said that you didn't violate when
the new york times reported the mosque
where they fired 700 rockets killing
four israelis
slaves said that palestinians were being
dehumanized by the headline that the
attacks were just the actions of people
who quote
just want to be free right as those
saying that and feeling that
justifies killing innocent people right
all the time
really that's your excuse well and this
would this would be an you know okay
hold on a second maybe she just misspoke
four or five 18 times a day with moss
and palestine
but possible a picture with a hezbollah
hamas supporter and she refused to
denounce the picture
right i think we have a picture right
here from the times of israel boom yeah
she after she she was the decline to go
to israel
hamas came out and supported her she
supports them they support her rashida
hamas hamas rasheeda
rashida hamas yeah it's a reciprocal
relationship very nice oprah uma
terrorists michigan's 13th district
it's amazing to me again again several
times she's
equated palestine palestinians and hamas
uh another thing that's really important
this is something that really changes
the context here
of the visit to israel which she begged
for and then
grandstanded and said i wouldn't do is
uh mifta we have to
i don't know how it's pronounced um some
people may not know this something close
but this is important for why she was
barred to israel
uh ill on omar and rashida claibs their
trip to israel it was planned and
sponsored by a group called
mifta okay it's a palestinian
organization that has published
neo-nazi manifestos attacking jews
openly celebrating
violent islamic terrorism they
specifically celebrate
do we have any examples do you think we
have an example do you have examples
yes we do the group specifically
celebrated an attack on israel that
killed 38 people 13 of whom were
children
uh as well as suicide bomber i think who
uh killed uh was it 21 and
yeah was that what it was yeah i don't
know we have an overlay there think
about this context for a second we're
all talking about how she's been barred
from israel and how
they can't just borrow people with
unpopular opinions the people the group
organizing talib's trip
right yeah it was a group that advocates
suicide bombings that killed israel and
scores of
kill people in israel scores of jews
this is this is a good this is a bombing
right here some b-roll after the bombing
i want to show the actual bombing
because we'll get removed from youtube
so the people organizing the trip for
her to go to israel are people who want
to see the destruction of israel i think
it's also really important kind of like
we were talking about with antifa not
long ago
find me the examples of her openly and
expressly condemning hamas
right this is these are terrible people
they do not represent the palestinian
people no she's the one
who creates this equivalency between
them and compare this by the way to the
guilt by association to republicans
right people get really upset
because donald trump retweeted a guy who
has a pepe meme right
or david duke said something in support
of mitch mcconnell on his twitter i have
no idea right now look at this it's
clearly the party of white supremacy
and by the way we're going to talk more
so about the uh the uh uh the the
twitter blocking
think about that that comparison right
it's like oh this is a white supremacist
why well
why would david duke endorse him
otherwise they would do support barack
obama in a lot of ways if you look at
this guilt by association
of course you cannot tar and feather
somebody because there are some
unsavory supporters that's not what's
happening here if we're going to talk
about
the the the ties right the unless i have
to use the word unsavory but let's just
use
unsavory ties which is unfortunate
because terrorist food is delicious you
could use that the
unsavory ties supports hamas uh
has openly i guess palled around with
organizations
that have also supported hamas and
hezbollah and published
neo-nazi manifestos by the way could you
imagine if this would have happened on
the right if donald trump oh my gosh
retweeted or actually had an
organization right spoke for an
organization
that had publicly published nazi
manifestos
neo-nazi manifestos and this is
something i've talked about many times
before i want to hear what you think
when you look at islamists particularly
places like
like uh hamas or hezbollah or isis
al-qaeda or really any islamic
government where they have death for
apostasy and you're a lot
they're basically just nazis who beat
their wives and these are the people
rashida slave
is in bed with these are the people who
for talking about money in politics
who's beholden to who who's pulling the
strings well guess what
i have far less of a problem not saying
it's great with even big banks
or even the koch brothers than i do with
terrorists
pulling the strings like in freddy
krueger 3 the dream warriors at that
point
hey there youtube viewer you know the
drill just click one of these other
videos in a box
playing up here and i mean there's an
actual box i don't of course mean that
in the feminine
it's a slur but that of course i don't
mean box because men can have boxes too
and i don't mean to say
box i just that men can there's like a
dc outlet and ac outlet and they can be
either one that they choose depending on
the electrical current
or the charge of ions i think